instacart is the u.s. is leading grocery
delivery firm valued at eight billion
dollars it employs some 200,000 people
called shoppers who pick items from
supermarket shelves for customers who
order through a phone app and it says it
will add 300,000 more shoppers to meet
demand during the pandemic has people
self isolate in their homes the company
is presenting itself as a key service to
prevent the spread of covert 19 and the
shoppers at employees ask hashtag
household heroes but that's not how the
shoppers themselves feel their
recommendation was so absurd it was for
a customer to you know stick their hand
out their door and for us to try and
scan their ID at a distance which is it
would be funny if it weren't so
dangerous as part of the gig economy
instacart says it's just a software
platform hiring independent contractors
so workers exposed daily to infected
surfaces and supermarkets have had to
buy their own hand sanitizer and
disinfecting wipes and instacart doesn't
provide employee benefits like sick pay
there's a full sense of security in
ordering grocery delivery that it's
mitigating risks and it's it's not
exposing you because you're sheltered in
place well the reality is that we're
coming in contact with this virus and we
are going to become vectors of this
virus because we don't have proper
personal protective equipment and we
don't have any meaningful sick pay as
the pandemic spreads so to do wildcat
strikes across the united states
shipyard workers in maine poultry
workers in georgia sanitation workers in
pittsburgh all demanding protection if
they're the ones who are going to keep
society running co-payments or any type
of bill we risk our life every time we
grab a garbage bag workers at amazon
warehouses have also gone on strike
around the country demanding protection
this strike in Staten Island on Monday
the latest action your order is
hand-picked by a professional
human-faced with a strike instacart says
it will soon supply hand sanitizer and
institute a system of bonuses for some
it'll pay workers up to 14 days of sick
pay for those diagnosed with
virus until early May but with many
workers uninsured and tests in short
supply it's difficult for instacart
workers to qualify workers also want an
extra five dollars in order and hazard
pay the upsurge in industrial action
sparked by the pandemic is combining
with a trend that was already underway
in the US last year we had the most
strikes that we've had in more than a
decade and now as we confront this
pandemic workers aren't afraid anymore
to take big risks because no worker
wants to die for a job that doesn't
treat them well workers are scared of
losing their jobs they're a lot more
scared of losing their lives the
pandemic is highlighting the deep
economic fault lines and us society as
it becomes clear that there is often
with the fewest labor protections and
lowest wages are the ones whose labor is
essential and that society as a whole is
only as safe as they are sheer brute
hands the al jazeera Washington